so the last paper for this panel is by
Melissa ran an art historian and curator
Melissa Iran has written on American art
from the 18s to the 20th century she's
co-author with tioga war ii Stebbins jr.
of American paintings at Harvard vol.1
paintings watercolors and pastels by
artist born before 1826 published by
yale university press in nineteen oh
sorry in 2014 ron has published wildly
on life magazine including life in color
Life magazine and the color reproduction
of works of art published in a
collection bright modernity collar
Commerce and consumption in global
perspective edetate edited by liebe
logic and mark Stoneman and to articles
the famous flag reason I Ajima revisited
in history of photography and within
their walls life magazines eliminations
published in archives of American Art
journal in 2014 her 2013 essay on the
reception of the 1913 armory show in the
popular press received an award from the
research society for American
periodicals she is currently completing
a book on life's magazines role in
America in the American art world and an
additive volume on corporate patronage
in the United States
Thank You tatianna for the introduction
and thank you to the conference
organizers and also to Yale and the
tariff foundation for this organizing
this conference while much attention has
been paid to life magazine's place in
the history of photojournalism and
especially to life's photography during
World War Two life's Commission of war
art during the period has been largely
overlooked although i should say i'm
very excited by katherine specs book on
the women wore artists will hear later
about that modeled in part on american
19th century magazines and illustrated
newspapers that hired artists to paint
and draw life on both battlefields and
home fronts as well as on 20th century
british precedents life's war art
program was its largest patronage
project between 1941 and 1945 life sent
29 artists all over the world to
destinations from the Aleutians to
ascension island to record and paint all
aspects of war for more time
preparations on the homefront to
skirmishes at sea from combat action in
the jungles to wounded and shell-shocked
soldiers from aerial raids to bombed out
buildings and bridges from soldiers at
play two soldiers at rest between
battles covering the war was central to
life's mission from its inaugural issue
life positioned itself on the front
lines indeed Henry Luce promised in his
1936 prospectus that life's readers
would I witness great events early on
life's editors and staff members
recognized the need for both written and
visual documentation of world war two
and its pages and from the beginning
they envisioned both photographic and
painted images of the war as part of
their weekly picture stories on
September first 1939 the same day that
Hitler invaded Poland times circulation
director pierpont Prentice wrote a memo
to life managing editor john shaw
billings it is 80 years since the Civil
War but everybody still remembers the
Civil War drawings and Harper's and
Leslie's weekly it is 25 years since the
world war but everybody still remembers
the
or drawings in the illustrated london
weeklies and i sincerely hope that we
are not so set in our devotion to the
camera that we won't put a staff of
first-class illustrators to work right
away drawing the war news life's idea to
commission war art was certainly not
something new indeed in both the United
States and Britain there was a long
tradition of sending artists reporters
to the various fronts in 1941 life's
editors had also seen the british war
art exhibition at the museum of modern
art where they would have seen world war
one ERA works such as edward wadsworth
dazzle ships at dry dock at Liverpool
and Paul Nash's void as well as more
recent depictions from world war two
such as Henry Moore shelter drawings and
Graham Sutherland devastation 1940
series clearly inspired by the works on
exhibition shortly after life editor
Margot Varga wrote an article for the
magazine of art which asked Britain
mobilizes her artists what about America
viewing the exhibition at the MoMA
likely reinforced life's intent to start
a serious war art program earlier that
year life had already commissioned
american artists to depict national
defense preparations for a special issue
in life the resulting issue featured
more pages in color than ever before
printed in a single life issue that same
year just prior to the bombing of Pearl
Harbor life managing editor Daniel
longwell wanted to cover events in this
a couple more pages from that long
spread which is actually 20 pages long
that same year just prior to the bombing
of Pearl Harbor life managing editor
Daniel longwa wanted to cover events in
the North Atlantic and since he couldn't
get a photographer into argentia in
Newfoundland to paint the USS prairie
which at that time was doing almost
secret convoy duty longwall persuaded
the Navy to allow one of life's war
artists Tom Lee aboard the destroyer
clearly one reason for commissioning
paintings during wartime stemmed from
necessity while life especially during
the first years of World War two could
not send photographers to certain places
due to wartime restrictions they could
send painters who in the opinion of the
edgars could quote omit sensible
material from his canvas and still
produce an effective picture which a
photographer could not do Navy admiral
Hepburn who permitted Tom Lee to paint
aboard his ship also commented on the
cam
limitations during wartime and the
necessity for artists to document the
war and paint he said the modern camera
in spite of its great scope and
versatility has definite limitations
particularly during night actions and
foul weather or four battles which take
place over wide expanses of sea and sky
these phases of warfare however may be
depicted by an artist who not only can
capture the dramatic intensity of an
action and put it on canvas but also by
proper use of his skill can make scenes
and activity more vivid and poignant
stressing and integrating essential
elements and omitting unimportant
details thus for life editor's painting
was an essential supplement to its
photographic coverage in their view the
combination of paintings drawings
photographs and texts could not only
better tell the whole story it also
distinguished life's reporting from that
of its peers and competitors as life
editor Edward Kay Thompson later
reflected quote other publications
didn't have the graphic approach which
put our readers right at the ringside
you've heard scores of people say that
life outdid the newspapers in reporting
the war life's decision to send artists
to cover war did not go unnoticed and in
November of 1942 Lieutenant General
Breton Somerville issued a directive
requesting that the chief of engineers
for the US Army form a group of artists
to paint the war this decision to start
such a program was likely influenced by
life success and in a memo to loose
Daniel long well expressed concern about
what would happen to life's war artists
now that the government wanted to send
artists to war he wrote on research I
discovered today that directive from the
Secretary of War has set up a committee
consisting of Henry varnum poor David
Finley George Biddle and Ed Rowan to
carry out a project of sending civilian
artists out as war correspondence this
is exactly the scheme we have been
following for the past two years now we
have the spectacle of the War Department
with unlimited funds competing against
private industry and indeed we have them
keep competing for personnel long well
feared the next step would be the
elimination of life's opportunity to
send artists to cover the war as the
government would be employing artists
for a similar task long walls fears were
short-lived as was the government's war
art program by the spring of
42 the War Department art advisory
committee had been officially formed
with 42 artists hired as part of the
army art program by the summer of
nineteen forty-three Congress had failed
to appropriate funds for a continuation
of the program while some congressmen
supported the proposal including a was
robertson of virginia who argued that
the camera could not substitute for the
painters personal apprehension of the
war reasoning that though quote we can
take photographs of what happens in
europe it takes the vision and artistic
skill of the artist to bring us
inspiration which only an artist can put
down on canvas the war our program was
strongly opposed by others such as
democratic congressman joe Starnes of
alabama who wrote the project off as a
piece of foolishness in the end the war
program was cut and in June 1943 when
the 71 billion dollar war bill was
passed 43 artists lost their physicians
life came to the rescue as soon as
Daniel long we'll heard the news he
immediately went to see the Assistant
Secretary of War John McCoy and offered
to employ all the civilian artists that
had been formally working for the War
Department as part of life's war art
program out of 19 applica civilians 17
decided to join life's ranks and life
was once more in command of the largest
war art program in the United States
life allowed its artists great latitude
asking only of its artists that they
paint what they saw in the style they
deem most appropriate to the subject
George piddle who was initially in
charge of the US government's
short-lived war art program but went on
to paint for life outlined the war
artists task in a memo writing you are
not sent out merely as a news gatherer
you have been selected as outstanding
American artists who will record the war
in all its phases and its impact on you
as artists and as human beings what we
insist on is the best work you are
individually capable of and the most
integrated picture of war and all its
phases any subject is in order if as
artists you feel it is part of war
battle scenes and front lines battle
landscapes and the wounded the dying and
the dead prisoners of war field
hospitals and base hospitals wrecked
habitations and bombing scenes character
sketches of our own troops
of prisoners of the natives of the
country you visit the nobility courage
cowardice cruelty boredom of war omit
nothing duplicate to your heart's
content you may be guided by blakes
mysticism by Goya cynicism and sad
savagery or by dela Paz romanticism by
domi ace humanity and tenderness or
better still follow your own inevitable
star life's war artist sought to capture
all aspects of war and they rendered
their varied experiences in a wide
variety of styles and media from quick
spent pencil sketches and delicate
watercolors to expressive and even
cubist style oil paintings such as these
by reuben Kadesh bernard perlin covered
events in greece in a series of
narrative figurative paintings that life
later published in its februari 26 1945
issue life assigned artist Miller sheets
to report on India where he chose to
paint the starving poor and scenes of
suffering civilians and stark expression
acidic images life war artist David
Frieden Thal accompanied a Marine unit
on a night attack on Japanese occupied
island in the South Pacific that
resulted in a powerful series of
paintings later that year he went to
Yugoslavia to cover Tito's partisans and
he was the first to depict the Russian
army in Yugoslavia at a time when
neither allied reporters nor
photographers were allowed access to the
Russian front of all of the images
produced by life war artists one of the
most common images was that of
architectural destruction resulting from
more and for more on these images there
were over 500 of these kind of images
that circulated in life during the war
I'm see my recent essay and Joanne
Mancini and Keith Bresnan president's
volume on Life magazine and
architectural destruction while
stationed in Britain for example the
American artist Byron Thomas regularly
painted ruins both secular and sacred in
a variety of styles including this
painting of Coventry Cathedral and ruins
with its empty tracery set against a
dusky sky and scraggly Crosslake tree
form at the center it is both a haunting
depiction of present-day destruction and
reminiscent of the romantic landscapes
of Caspar David Friedrich Thomas also
painted and surrealist rendering of
ghosts like streets of East End London
as well as ruined residences replete
with Victory Gardens such images of
ruined buildings with Gardens
additionally connected to the garden
ruined tradition often found in
picturesque landscapes whether painted
or a part of an English countryside
life's artists were not the only ones to
link the destroyed buildings resulting
from World War two to garden ruins on
August fifteenth nineteen forty four in
response to proposals to either rebuild
or restored the damaged cathedrals of
England sir kenneth clark who is also
the chair of the british war artist
advisory committee john maynard keynes
TS Eliot and other prominent
intellectuals and art historians wrote a
letter to the London Times which called
to preserve the bomb damage churches in
their ruined condition as permanent
memorials of the war in 1945 they
published their proposal as a pamphlet
entitled bomb churches as war memorials
the book included sketches of the ruined
buildings as they would look if allowed
to both naturally and artificially grow
and to garden ruins a proposal which to
paraphrase historian Christopher
Woodward could only have originated in
England life's war artist stationed in
England not only painted romantic images
of wartime ruins but also unlike what
life's war artist stationed elsewhere in
the world spent much time depicting the
daily experiences of the British people
during the war as well as scenes of
American soldiers interacting with
British civilians ranging from images of
East End children entertaining
themselves among broken walls and bomb
shelters to a meditative scene of an
American soldier and a Scottish
companion gazing across the river tay
and perth two paintings of an
international mix of soldiers and
civilians listening to a nine o'clock
news broadcast in scotland even when
portraying the arrival of american
planes in england's airfields in advance
of d-day as shown here in ogden place
nurs painting or in byron Thomas's
painting of their arrival of an American
transport ship in England one gets the
sense of a shared cause and experience
of war that the British and American
people troops and artists are indeed in
the same boat in fact the caption
beneath this picture describes how quote
this little British cutter
we'll steer the American ship safely in
indeed many of the captions and titles
that accompanied images of the British
front often had a tone of solidarity and
empathy of working together in the fight
as well as the emotional toll that the
war took such as in this headline that
said British are battered but bored by
the long war which accompanied a
painting by the American artist Aaron
bow rod life hired artists to paint the
war to lend variety and also credibility
to its pictorial reporting in an
internal memo to fellow publisher Andrew
high school Roy Larson wrote quote
strangely enough despite the fantastic
success of life and other picture
magazines news photography is not a
respectable profession and the
photograph is not considered to be a
complete and accurate medium for the
reproduction of news and general
information indeed as life articulated
in early nineteen forty-three
advertisement the objective was quote to
get a series of pictures that will make
life readers feel they have actually I
witnessed the great events taking place
at the front and for them that could not
be accomplished through the photograph
alone indeed although life employed some
of the world's best photographers its
editors were well aware of the technical
limitations of the camera even though by
the 1920s and 30s more compact and
portable cameras had been developed with
faster film more powerful lenses and
accelerated shutter speeds the camera
could not capture anything everything
moreover both before and during World
War two color photography was not
technically advanced enough to shoot all
aspects of war and life clearly wanted
to supplement its black-and-white
photographic coverage with color images
as Daniel longwa wrote in a memo when
the war broke out those of us who got
around the country at various training
camps realized color had to be used I
took a trip out to visit the Marines at
Elliot field in San Diego and the Army
at Fort Sam Houston and one of the
things I remember about the war artists
was that Eastman had not yet developed
the fast color film and the color film
procedure was too slow to report the war
in action thus the war artist could
record with their pencil brush or pen
what the photographer cannot capture
with a camera due to both technical and
environmental limitations as well as
security
and military restrictions artists could
also add in details that they would not
have been able to photograph at the time
because of safety issues or physical or
visual obstructions paintings unlike
photographs could also present the
events of war in a continuous narrative
within one picture whereas a photograph
reproduces the appearance of one
instance from one point of view a
painter could construct his image to
show a progression of events within a
single scene or to even show multiple
viewpoints simultaneously indeed many of
life's war artists had prior
professional training and knew well the
pictorial conventions for both history
and narrative painting and utilize them
as they render depictions of battles or
other events of war as life war artist
Fletcher Martin argued his paintings
were more personal and perhaps at least
in terms of the subjective emotional
experience of war even more accurate
than the camera he wrote the painter can
make a more personal statement than the
camera his record can be stronger than
the cameras because he can eliminate
unnecessary detail and concentrate on
the significant some of my work that
digressed frankly from actuality met the
approval of the fighting men themselves
they responded to it and said I'd got
the feel of the action that was the acid
test furthermore unlike the photograph
which had to be made on the spot and the
serves as an indexical record of the
photographer having been there a
painting could variously be painted on
site be made after the fact or from
memory who could even conjecture what
might happen this allowed artists to
capture events they may have been
otherwise impossible and many of the war
artists actually kept lengthy journals
and sketchbooks to record their thoughts
so that they could paint from memory
when they returned to their studios in
some cases life even reproduced some of
the artist sketch books such as this
these of Erin bow rod and Byron Thomas
who in 1944 six days after the Normandy
invasion hitchhiked their way from
England across France and arrived at
Omaha Beach life reprinted their sketch
book in its october 9th 1944 issue and
come when compared with Robert Kappas
powerful photographs of d-day that were
published in life in 1945 they
demonstrate how different media offered
varied views of the war for life the
combination of paintings drawings and
photo
graphs and text could better tell the
whole story as Daniel long will later
recollected although we covered the war
with our camera better than any other
Illustrated magazine had ever covered
the war it was our painters who added
the extra ten percent that made the show
truly notable life not only reproduced
many of these paintings and its weekly
pages they also celebrated them in a
series of traveling exhibitions in 1943
life's war art exhibition opened at the
National Gallery of Art in Washington
before traveling to the metropolitan
museum of art were over 26,000 people
attended the show the exhibition
displayed 122 paintings and watercolors
prints and drawings that were made in
the United States battle zones by nine
of life's war artists Frances Hannah
Taylor the director of the Metropolitan
Museum of Art in his introduction to the
catalog contextualized life's war art
within the history of art comparing them
to such iconic history paintings as
Benjamin West death of General Wolfe and
Lloyds as Washington Crossing the
Delaware Taylor then went on to
emphasize that what distinguished life's
War art from earlier examples was that
artists like west & Lloyd's of quote
were seldom eyewitnesses to the scenes
they depicted instead their works were
painted out of the fragments of
recollection hear the word of an
eyewitness there and a liberal dash of
romantic imagination from somewhere else
in contrast Taylor argued life's artists
reporters observed history in the raw an
aspect which struck Taylor as having
high significance and after its showing
at the Met it went on a nationwide tour
the show was incredibly popular with the
public in part due to life's extensive
publication of many of these pictures
and its pages throughout the war but the
art received mixed reviews from the
critics Edward aldenjewell writing for
The New York Times was initially
skeptical and remarked that at first he
doubted that painters could compete with
the camera but after seeing the
exhibition his opinion was tellingly
reshaped and he wrote the exhibition as
a whole is impressive it contains much
fine and serious work by American
artists who have been provided with
every opportunity to observe their
material at close range often intimately
and is the intimate personal penetrating
perceptive touch indeed that is equipped
to furnish a chapter that would be
missing where the camera excludes
we relied upon this manifest
preponderantly on the human side our
digest associate editor mod Riley simile
stated that the works on display make a
thrilling story one more real than words
reproductions and news photographs Riley
further singled out Peter herds
depiction of a tail gunner and Tom lees
paintings of the Hornet as especially
powerful a reviewer for The New Yorker
likewise lauded life for recording the
war and paint and wrote quote it's a
good thing for all of us that life
undertook the job for his things have
turned out if it hadn't done so we would
now have practically no artistic record
of the fighting so far in contrast
Jerome elk was writing for the nation
labeled the artist feeble recorders and
critique their art on display at the met
as conveying little all too little of
wars calamity heroism humor depth and
grief and further criticized the
institutions who hosted the exhibition
for displaying such weak examples like
some critics some artists also found
life's war are to be superficial
unemotional and uncritical in 1944 a
group of leftist artists each of whom
for different reasons had not gone to
the Front's protested life's traveling
exhibition of war art which was
currently on display at the Met by
mounting a show of their own organised
by artist Fernando Puma at his gallery
on west 57th Street in New York the
exhibition entitled we challenge war art
argued that life could not be left
unchallenged Puma and his fellow artists
in the exhibition including max where
George gross Victor fall John growth
William proper and Seymour Lipton thus
offered their alternative view of the
war as soon as life got wind of the
exhibition they published a spread on
Puma show life reported quote mr. Puma
believes that these pictures are better
than the painting records done by life
war artist correspondence at the front
because they expressed the psychological
or philosophical reaction of artists to
war life photograph the rebel artists
with their paintings and reproduced in
color George grosses expressive and
powerful I was always present Pumas they
will not conquer and William droppers
Pearl Harbor among other works life
concluded the article by asking the
readers to judge the issue for
themselves many readers reply to the
article some thanking life for the
provocative art store
while others were appalled that those
who did not go to the front would
attempt to paint what they had not
experienced another reader argued in
favor of Pumas exhibition stating the
painting in the exhibition are much more
powerful and telling than the works of
life's war artist correspondence life
even conducted its own informal poll of
art critics art history professors
museum directors and printed the most
common response concluding quote it all
depends on the man behind the brush in
just five years life's war artist
correspondence produced over 1,000
paintings drawings and watercolours
hundreds of which were reproduced in
life both during and after the war up to
mid nineteen forty four life had printed
approximately 160 reproductions of the
670 oils watercolors and sketches that
had been done up to that time and a
total of four hundred and sixty-seven
had been reproduced in life by may nine
teen 46 the collection of war are
remained at life until nineteen sixty
when during the week of the 19th
anniversary of Pearl Harbor the 10 1050
works in the life collection of art from
World War two were presented to the
Department of Defense by editor in chief
Henry Robinson loose in a ceremony at
the Pentagon although law often left out
of histories of American Art the
thousands of paintings produced by Life
magazine artists during World War two
were not only important documents of the
war and form a significant part of the
artistic production of the 1940s in
America they were also some of the most
controversial works of the period
generating both popular and critical
praise as well as protest shaping the
American public's perception of the
varied fronts of our enemies and allies
during World War two thank
you